this is a cycle of a business I'm going
to take one little idea and I'm gonna
turn it into this 80 000 a year to go to
Stanford Harvard MIT or Yale and never
learn this process it's a true story I'm
gonna write the millionaire booklet
watch what I do I'm driving home from uh
downtown Miami it was a charity event
and I gave some money to help this
charity that night and I'm driving home
and Elena's like I'm so proud of you
grant you did such a good thing tonight
I get home and I'm like I'm gonna write
a book tonight how to become a
millionaire most of you would sit down
and start writing the book what I did
next was write an offer I'm like okay
this book is going to be uh 1995. I'm
going to sell it for 9.95 it's going to
be a pre-order I'm literally calling
Sherry at midnight give me a landing
site right now we're going to call it
the millionaire book and share he's like
you can't write a book you're under
contract with penguin random right now
and they get your next book I said did
we agree to a book or a booklet she's
like a book book I said good don't call
it the millionaire book call it the
millionaire booklet okay if that don't
work we'll call it the millionaire
pamphlet okay let them sue me later need
motivation watch the top 10 with believe
Nation hey 7 Carmichael and I make these
videos because the thing that saved me
as an entrepreneur was watching the
stories of other successful
entrepreneurs and I learned from their
advice I learned from their motivation
and honestly I have no idea where I
would be if I didn't have those videos
to inspire me I still need them for
myself today too and I hope that they
can inspire you as well so today let's
learn from one of the best Grant Cardone
and my take on his top 10 rules of
success enjoy
in the mind the mind says oh I'm going
to write a book and
book and you think I need to finish a
product I need to start selling books
okay now I need to Market this book well
Grant the book's not finished right now
okay ain't nobody coming to your house
at 12 30 at night to get the book I
started advertising money I got a book
so you guys won't do that
you're like but I don't have a book I
got a book I got time nobody expects to
get the book in an instant I had a
landing page up see this landing page we
added the video the next day so idea
offer Market notice I haven't written
anything now I'm going to sell it I'm
gonna close the fifth step will be to
deliver a service so what am I going to
do here right here you gotta write your
book okay I had this idea at 11 o'clock
at night at 11 20 I think we got our
first order 20 minutes after it and then
I go online and say hey guys if you
could help me translate my new book into
Arabic Hebrew can you please do this for
me and I'll give you credit for the
translation 38 languages in 30 days and
I paid a whopping zero more importantly
I got the word out on this new book now
I gotta write the book by one o'clock in
the morning 1am the book was finished
now you're like man how do you write a
book so fast because I was selling books
fast honesty integrity and ethics they
have power I commit to People by accept
their money the moment people start
giving me money I'm like oh I gotta
deliver now if you're a good person you
should have good things coming your way
if you don't have good things coming
your way and you're a good person that's
because something in your business cycle
is broken rule number two is invest in
real estate how can I own real estate
control real estate use the cash I have
in the bank to buy a piece of real
estate and have enough tenants pay me a
check every month
I didn't do it the way my uncle did it
my uncle did it one house at a time I
did it 100 units at a time my first deal
was 38 units my second deal was 48 units
my third deal was 90 units now we don't
even look at deals outside we we that
size we look at deals 400 units 500
units now why am I telling you this and
what should you take away from this
okay my first real estate deal was one
house I bought one house
I rented it and as soon as they moved
out I had problems I had to sell the
house just like my mom had to sell the
house so the first thing I want you to
know is this not all real estate makes
you money this is a piece of real estate
right here this guy paid 19 million
maybe 20 million bucks to build this
house he's going to sell it for 16
million dollars okay I come here I abuse
the damn place for two or three weeks
pay the guy 150 or 300 grand for two
weeks or three weeks that we stay here
and I walk away okay he gets income from
one person or eight people a year eight
people nine people maybe 10 people a
year maybe 12 people maybe he rents it
every week
but he won't do that every year because
if it doesn't snow he won't run it
don't buy single family homes when
somebody's not in it you got to make the
paycheck you got to pay the check okay
when I rent when I buy a hundred units
or 40 units or 30 units okay my first
deal was 38 units I never had less than
34 of those 38 units rented never did I
have less than 34 out of the 38 units
rented which was enough money to pay the
pay the the the note at the bank to to
pay for the roof to be fixed to pay the
paint the tenants termites the toilets
the classified ads the problems
something my mama told me one day she's
like you don't want to get in real
estate people are going to be calling
you at midnight I'm like I wish somebody
would call me I've been busting my ass
my whole damn life so somebody would
call me God damn if somebody would call
me that means they're paying me or they
want to pay me
so what you gonna do
see your parents have half of everything
right
if they're millionaires they got half of
the equation right they got just enough
money now to say hey I made a bunch of
money I took care of my kids I got them
a college degree we got a nice house and
if I get a divorce it's going to cost me
half that's all the millionaires
nobody tells you that though nobody
tells you that look if you want to make
if you want real Freedom that's what my
dad wanted to provide my mom real
freedom and he never got there because
the week after my dad died my mom had to
sell that house that is not freedom
there was no debt on the house
except for the death the government puts
on every piece of property in America
property taxes okay and if you can't pay
the property taxes if you can't pay for
the Landscaping if you can't pay to have
the lawn mowed the snow to be picked up
and moved okay the pain to be fixed the
cedar the cedar Shake that's going to
fall off this place the roof that's
going to get damaged over some period of
time
if you can't fix all that it's coming
out of your pocket you're going to be
worried when you go to sleep at night
that's why I buy apartments and Office
Buildings because they provide income
from multiple tenants at one piece of
property it could be a hundred units 200
units 500 units the bigger the bigger
the more units the more protection you
get okay listen to what I'm telling you
that's one unit big nice big ass badass
house right beautiful
okay I'm gonna give them 200 Grand 300
Grand
I'm gonna walk away from this place
okay that one section of the roof over
there could cost him 300 Grand one year
and it will by the way that roof will
not last forever it's got a 25-year life
he's got Plumbing issues here he's got
electrical Heating in the floors okay
you know the bridge is going to be a
problem we got water fountains swimming
pools that swimming pool's been at 106
degrees since I got here I'm like Crank
that bad boy all the way up who do you
think's paying the utility bill here not
me
so look not all real estate makes you
money the real estate that makes you
money is the real estate that produces
income every month positive cash flow
cash flow is the Holy Grail
the Holy Grail of all Finance is cash
flow rule number three is focus on
making money a lot of people watch our
videos they aspire to assets properties
Yachts like this and they should what
would be some of the advice that you
would give them what I would recommend
to people is like number one lock-in
that success is important and finances
are vital like you need money and you
need a lot of money number one you need
whatever you think about money you're
wrong
and and I'm telling you you're wrong
because you ain't never had any money
or been around anybody with any money so
you can't you shouldn't be making any
decisions about money it's crazy to me
how many people make decisions about
money and never had any and never had
anybody around them that had any money
so most of the people that say money
will make you happy and it won't do this
and it won't do that I'm like you don't
know anything about money you should you
should just have a clean slate and say I
don't know anything about money so money
is important number two uh don't lose
money you need to invest in that's
guaranteed to make you money once you
earn it man take it and use it for
something that will make you more money
don't keep it don't save it don't Ira it
don't 401K it don't go buy Gucci and
crime shoes don't do any of that
in the beginning okay yeah no
no it's a terrible
you need you need you need in the
beginning right you need money you need
you don't want to save even three months
of money I would not save that old
about say for a rainy day you
need a 90-day Reserve I wouldn't do any
of that if I was starting over today
I would go out and earn money I would
take all the money invest in something
that paid me a little drip and I'd go
out and earn some more money throw it in
another deal pays me a drip I'm not
talking about stocks I want to convert
paper to an asset that's worth more than
paper how's the cash flow and and so
most of these companies I mean we we're
going to look at a third of the
companies on the entire Stock Exchange
or zombie companies that will never
produce income ever and they're worth
billions of dollars they're garbage and
they're going to go into the dumper and
a lot of people are going to lose a lot
of money gambling on this so
that's what I'll tell you man money's
important number two don't lose it once
you get it use it you'll lose it if you
don't use it saving money is is a is a
crazy stupid game you'll never get
wealthy doing that and the third thing
is surround yourself with great people
that are actually moving towards these
same things that are interested in money
and wealth rule number four is Inspire
others don't try to done trying to
impress anybody
but I do want to inspire people I want
to inspire you
so it's been my mission my mission has
been like if I make it one day I'm going
to show you guys behind the scenes you
get to see my wife
my kids how we conduct ourselves when we
go on trips when I'm on business when
I'm at home I want to show people what
it's like to make it okay I'm not
showing you all the cars and stuff and
the planes and to to like say look at me
look at me look at me I'm saying hey man
no
this is my strategic
literally my mission a strategic mission
is to show you everyday people whether
you live in in uh in Africa
or America
Venezuela
or you live in Venice Beach California
okay look there's broke people in both
those places
there's hopeful people in both those
places men women kids I don't care your
age your sex your sexual preferences
you're doing drugs not doing drugs you
believe in them or not you're a
republican a Democrat you're a con a
capitalist or a communist
my mission is not political a mission is
to like help people see that
what is possible also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is take care of
yourself a lot of you've been asking me
about my my workout regimen uh some of
you may or may not know but
two years ago I couldn't do a push-up I
wasn't in terrible shape but man my body
was starting to hurt
you know I'm 63 years old so
there's no way you can't you can hold on
to it without doing the work and when I
was a kid
I was for whatever reason my metabolism
uh genetics whatever I was never uh
as always I could just pick it up quick
physically fairly strong but you know
short sharp muscles and they would
respond really quickly
and then
I started believing I could get away
with that
and then you start hitting 40 45 and 50.
this is no way so what I what I did
today you just saw my morning basically
my my routine I changed it up a little
bit I'm in my recovery room right now
this is a magnet uh I'll I'll post some
of the things that it does and
uh some of the benefits of it but
basically
what you need to do is finish my workout
uh spent eight minutes on this magnet
it's basically electronic magnet that
separates the cells in the body and gets
everything where it's supposed to be
it's like oxygenating all my cells then
I'll go to the egg over here sauna
and by the way I any of you that want
any of these products let me know I
represent all of them
that is a hyper Pro it has a 30 minute
30-minute uh sauna it Heats to 194
degrees
Corona cannot live it runs in real
Corona cannot live it 140.
and that's sauna to what a place to
relax man amazing
so I'll spend 30 minutes in that
[Music]
I'll spend 30 minutes in the sauna and
then I'll do 20 minutes into infrared
bed this is a Mack Daddy right here this
bed right here is 28 thousand dollars
put that here's I don't know if you can
even get one
that's a hundred and uh it's the best in
the world 80 000 lights invisible
lighting like it is fantastic for
immunity runs off of a pad over here so
I can pull up everything from
uh inflammation joint pain pain
recovery anti-aging sleep immunity
energy soft tissue recovery so these are
three things I do every day rule number
six is study recession one thing I was
gonna say Brian and granted as I know
coming up you talked earlier about the
recession Grant I know Brian our our
followers and audience are just Avid
about taking action that's one thing
that's great is and that's something you
teach probably Let's Take Action so
Grant you know maybe you guys both talk
a little bit about the upcoming um
challenge you're doing which I love one
of the topics is really how to thrive
during challenges in the recession some
of the things you're going to be
teaching because I think it's so
important everybody that's following you
Brian all of our subs they really need
to get involved in this because it's
some really good stuff on what I heard
Grant talking about this a few months
ago
like if you guys agree with my statement
about you know sometimes the truth is
not is a painful pill to take
and and as much as the truth might hurt
folks we are going we have 13 trillion
dollars worth of debt in this country
that was taken on in the last two years
oh wow
this is more this is more debt than than
his like we printed almost 80 percent of
all the US dollars in circulation yeah
happened in the last 36 months now
you're like okay well what what does
that mean it means you should have got a
pay raise
if you didn't get a pay raise you did
not get a part of the print
which means your hustle's off
uh inflation uh Warren Buffett says
inflation is it's it's a it's the most
misunderstood Concept in the world and
most people when they hear the word
inflation they get scared but the truth
is your assets should have gone up in
value
the things that you own should have gone
up in value if you have wealth already
you should embrace inflation
if you don't have wealth then you have
to be like okay I got to start getting
some assets because they benefit from
inflation yes and you don't need money
to buy assets but you do need a strategy
and you need a commitment a Target yeah
so like my little company this year last
year we did 145 million dollars in
internet sales in a 12-month period wow
like I don't even have an inventory I
don't have inventories like like I built
this out of recessions to become
Unbreakable
because I've been broke so many times
that I'm like I don't want to keep
getting going backwards you know like I
can't keep going back because I got to
figure out what there's something I
don't know and don't understand
so I had like I had 401 case IRAs I had
a house paid for I got rid of all that
in 2008 sold the house
converted the money out of the house and
my IRA accounts to start making
Investments
and and I quit playing by the house
rules Brian that you and I were brought
up on save your money 90-day reserves uh
buy house pay it off I'm like no I'm
investing all this money in me I'm an
investing in our customers and I'm
invested in my expansion
and so I would just tell everybody right
here Eric based on your question you
guys need to reassess what's an asset
and what's a liability right now right
okay and and because the game is
changing radically in a way you have
time to you have time to re you gotta
really challenge everything you've been
told uh by Wall Street and by your
education and by your friends and family
yes
um because a house is not going to make
you money it's never going to make you
money houses are not built to make money
and saving money in a bank helps the
bank but it doesn't help you in saving
money in IRAs and 401ks helps Wall
Street but it doesn't help you notice
who's getting wealthier the banks in
Wall Street not individuals rule number
seven is learn the sales game you want
to do something in life you got to learn
the sales game I know some of you might
be turning this up right now you're like
I don't want to know anything about
sales but before you turn it off
understand this
today I own about 750 million dollars
worth of real estate not all of it looks
like this
I've had homes and real estate in
California Arizona
Los Angeles
Austin Texas Alabama
Houston Texas let's see where else about
stuff I own about 5 000 apartments right
now
and I'm going to share something and I'm
going to give you the link below here so
that you can go grab this data I've
written seven books 19 best-selling
audio programs
an online platform that's over 30
million people have used and tested out
on companies that pay me hundreds of
millions of dollars to teach their teams
I'm telling you all that to tell you
this
there's one thing
in my entire life that I did to
accomplish everything that I have today
including my wife
and my kids and my free time all that
stuff
started
because I learned how to sell
I learned how to sell I learned how to
do something and by the way that I
didn't like to do I didn't like the
sales game didn't like the rejection you
know wasn't comfortable talking to
people not not really that comfortable
doing this video right now but I'm
willing to why
okay so there's two parts of this one
you got to learn the sales game at some
point I don't care what you do you want
to write a book you want to write a a
movie you want to sell a movie you want
to sell music you want to get people to
pick you up you want to be a celebrity
you want to be a DJ you know a plumber
contractor Dennis you got to learn how
to sell period rule number eight is
acquire assets my target my initial
Target in my life has been to work hard
and invest in assets that provide me
with passive income that protect my
Capital provide me with tax write-offs
passive income and mostly to not be in
fear about my money these assets that
we're buying today like this Heights
collection you can't destroy it you
can't get rid of it you can't burn it
down you can't earthquake it you can't
hurricane it it's going to be there
these properties and all the other
properties that I bought look at this we
bought this last year altice mocha 165
million dollar asset
the our bass property in Fort Lauderdale
we're making a big big big bets on Fort
Lauderdale Miami and Houston that deal
was 108 million dollars doing covid we
bought it distress for 98 million
dollars a great deal this property right
here I just closed on this this is in
Boca Raton uh 260. 230 units I wanted
this so bad it was a quick close to
stress sale off Market I wrote a check
for 69 million dollars for that property
if you guys are 35 years old 45 years
old 55 65 even 75 years old
I'm telling you get your money out of
the market quit gambling
okay the ETFs are a gamble listen the
ETFs are a gamble you think they're safe
and they're not the mutual funds are at
risk you think they're safe but I'm
telling you they're not what's safe is
real assets rule number nine is B
unbreakable we're coming into probably
what I Believe In Our Lifetime Brian you
and I this will be the biggest recession
of our lifetime you reckon bigger than
2008 and it's it because it's it's an
Institutional level this time it's not a
bunch of people that took mortgages out
on homes that's not where the problem is
the problem this time is with the
biggest players in the world
so what I was saying was like Hey so we
started planning this Eric I think I
talked to you about it back in June and
and here we are now we called it
unbreakable because we want to put
people in their households in a position
where they're unbreakable yes and the
thing about unbreakable is this okay you
cannot be unbreakable without money
this money topic sometimes people skirt
around and they don't talk about it but
um I've become famous and Infamous for
telling people you need more money you
know Brian you've written I don't know
90 books or something right most people
can't do that to get to know an audience
today it's what you had to do 20 years
ago to get an audience today you know we
can do this
yes this is the new book reading of the
21st century for good or for bad yes so
next week we're going to do five
90-minute classes
uh on really getting people to think
about how they can get themselves and
their family in the top one percent of
honors and remember Ten the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
go big I see 10x branding everywhere not
just in your conferences I feel like it
has become part of your branding what
does 10x represent all right 10x to next
was a discovery I made in 2008 when the
economy crashed I went from having some
money some net worth to like 2008 like
literally like I thought I was going to
lose everything we had a baby on the way
I was embarrassed that I'd put my family
in this situation I didn't have anything
to do with the mortgage crisis yet it
pulled everything with it it was like a
you know everybody got evicted dude
everybody it did you it didn't matter
who you were so I went and sat in my
office said how did I do this like
anytime I have a problem first thing I
look at after blaming everyone I look at
what did I do the one thing I didn't do
right
was I kept hearing this thing too big to
fail too big to fail and I'm like bro
they're telling you be too big to fail I
was too small I should have scaled I
needed to be bigger my wife said what
are we going to do different next time
and I'm like and when she says what are
we going to do different that means
she's gonna be the cheerleader and I'm
gonna go do it right which is cool I
need that partnership and and I said
next time this happens I will have 10
times the debt 10 times the assets and
10 times the companies today I owe two
billion dollars
I don't have three companies I have uh
17. we have 100 times more people to
talk to at least a hundred times maybe a
thousand times a bigger audience and
we're in 25 verticals not not two
so 10x basically is scale you got to get
big you don't have a choice if you want
to survive on this planet without
worrying every second of every day you
got to get big or you got to get a
partner you got to be with a partner
that's ready to scale
I am an extremely hard individual okay I
know what it takes to be in the position
I'm in it is not easy okay I have paid
attention for 30 years to everything
when it comes in and when it goes out
and where it goes and whether or not
this energy that came in or the energy I
put out hey does it actually pay me so
that I can produce something in the
future okay anybody anybody can have
this much success in life
to string it together for 32 years never
have a bankruptcy never not pay a debt
never ever ever okay walk away from
something I didn't know it is very very
difficult
going out knocking on the door making
some money getting a sale great winning
of course a case in court great okay
getting a degree to college good you can
do that okay anybody can do all that
stuff to string together 30 years
and be able to survive recessions okay I
am an extremely intelligent person when
it comes to money okay we're the most
resilient
people on the planet I mean except for
maybe persons
[Music]
I mean really persons are unbelievable
people okay okay in the Romans the
Romans were pretty successful okay but
but you notice if you look at those
civilizations man Persian wrote look
there was a time when they had
everything they had it all and they lost
it because they started making mistakes
they started thinking oh well we'll go
on forever we don't have to be diligent
we don't have to pay attention we don't
have to do the right things okay you
were on a ship
[Music]
you're on the same ship I'm on okay I
own the ship but guess what it won't
matter it won't matter when the ship
ship goes through rough orders hey your
stomach's gonna feel the same as mine
I'm not the only one that is scared in
these Waters I just know I ain't getting
off the ship
for you you actually can say and I'm
gonna get off I can't get off you
understand this is my show okay my
ship's gonna finish this trip I did 35
years of this I guarantee you I will die
on this ship okay and I will find other
places to go adventure and other places
to have victories and other
civilizations to meet okay this is my
trip and if you want to be on it with me
for the whole ride you can be you can
get off anytime you want to probably
half of you will at some point get off
say I'm done here I got that man we'll
pull into Port one day we'll drop the
what's that thing we'll drop the anchor
the gang walk means we push you off
hopefully you wait till we get to Port
and then you get off and then you walk
off into the village and you get uh some
some woman in the village pregnant and
you settle down there and you become a
new civilization whatever it's what we
used to do man it used to be cool
can you imagine back in that time hey
new place let's go visit the people hey
are we going to be here in the future
well one thousand percent are we gonna
do another 10 extra conference
guaranteed
okay I mean if I'm not gonna do another
one of those I'm not doing any like I'm
done I need to go home get on a ship and
travel around and and not come back to
work anymore are we gonna do are you
gonna buy more real estate oh for 100
sure
so you're not going to stop this brand
and and the the the desired people have
and my mission is to help people
so and I cannot do this by myself every
one of you is needed okay but I need you
I need you right now to lean into this
thing
your job depends on what you do every
day your job depends on
okay not not your job with me your job
period on this planet
depends on how much you take your
shoulder and put it against a wheel and
push and get a product a product
okay for us this products are people
know about Grant Cardone people know
about our webinars people know about our
opportunities people know about our
books I need you to do more than your
job I'm already paying you to do your
job
okay you're not going to get a bonus if
you don't do more than your job I'm just
telling you
bonus if he don't finish that movie
if the tickets don't sell Kevin Hart
will not get the bonus you have the MLB
baseball players for the Marlins they do
not get paid this year if there is no
season you understand that
they don't like I'll get my check anyway
you didn't play bro
okay if I get hurt in the NFL and I
don't play I don't get paid that's the
real world
so when I get to when I hear the numbers
in the morning sometimes you guys don't
see me there because when I hear we got
a hundred licensees I'm like God damn we
should have ten thousand and everybody
in this room should have sold one and
got a commission on it
so again if you don't like if you're in
shipping Sherry told me somebody in
shipping them like why is that person in
shipping when's that person how can that
person live on 16 an hour
or twenty dollars an hour we took them
down for 20. how can you live on twenty
dollars an hour
in Miami
okay I'm not going to pay any more for
the position
how can you make sense of it I don't I
don't understand that like
there's all this other stuff we have to
sell man everybody every time I meet
somebody coming to my boot camp coming
to my webinar you coming you got a book
you got this program you got a wristband
okay how about a t-shirt
like like every time I talk to somebody
I'm like once you grab one of my things
because I know that drives a little bit
of Exchange
once he gives me money he has a
relationship with me
the moment he gives me money we actually
complete the relationship it is only
then okay you guys that are on Natalie's
team you you can call and talk to these
people and help them as much as you want
you're not actually having a
relationship when you do this help
when they exchange back with you you
complete the health cycle okay they have
to give you something for the help
otherwise it's a handout
and nobody wants to handle
except people that have given up
and lost self-respect of themselves
nobody wants a handout they want a
little hey come on you know but nobody
they'll resent me if I keep giving them
a handout so remember when they say hey
I want something great make sure they
give you something back
okay so so that we can complete that
relationship or start one and we can
start actually doing business with one
another have you ever seen how people
talk about different days of the week
you know like oh man I hate Mondays or
Wednesday's hump day or hey thank God
it's Friday or my God I can't wait till
the weekend when you hear people say
things like Mondays this I hate it
Wednesday's hump day oh my God I can't
wait to the weekend you are talking to
people that whether they know it or not
are unproductive people unproductive
first in their minds limiting their
potential and their ability to produce
at higher levels because they are
basically taking four days of the week
and throwing them away I hate Mondays
Wednesday's hump day no Wednesday and
hump day do Wednesday is the fourth day
of the week first of all most people
don't know uh zilch about the days of
the week Sunday's the first day not the
last day Monday's the second day
Tuesday's the third day fourth day is
Wednesday the fifth day is Thursday
Friday's the sixth day and Saturday is
the finish of the week
otherwise you don't know what you're
talking about okay and you can't waste
any of them you only have a handful most
people don't even know how many Sundays
they have but they talk about their
weekends being the greatest time of
their life and the truth is most people
just get in trouble on the weekends okay
what am I telling you here I'm telling
you this got to start paying attention
to your time your thoughts your ideas
and you got to start paying attention to
the people that are around you and what
they think if the people you hang with
hate Mondays you're not going to be very
productive on Mondays would you agree if
Wednesdays is a day named after camels
and you don't live in the desert you're
just freaking confused and if the
weekend is the only thing you got
cherished boom you need to blow your
brains out because your life is going to
be long
ugly and unproductive saving money is
only good for banks I've been saying
this to people for a decade saving money
is basically A bank's program to keep
you imprisoned to the Banks Banks don't
save money they convince the American
public to save money and when they do
the bank then calls a guy like me up and
says hey Elijah's saving money over here
like an idiot and then brings the money
to Wells Fargo Bank of America Citibank
he dropped it off with us would you like
to borrow Mr Cardone like they're not
even keeping your money they're lending
it out tens of times people need to quit
saving money they need to quit planning
for retirement they need to invest money
back into themselves their business and
their household to produce more income
and I'm talking about second third and
fourth floors of income I'm not talking
about investing in the stock market
retirement accounts much less investing
in crypto people need to invest only in
things where they don't lose their money
and that income they earned provides
them with a second income because
they're investing their hard-earned
dollars not in consumer items but
Investments that will pay them cash flow
cash flow is the Holy Grail cash is
garbage it's a Fiat it's a complete
mythology the cash is worth anything
it's not but most American families keep
trying to hustle money and then save it
only to find out it goes down in value
buys less and less each year and they
never get ahead when I was a kid when I
was growing up
the guy that the guy that knew how to
take care of his environment was my dad
was eight years old and then this dude
this dude controlled everything in this
environment
and he left early for work he came home
late
took care of his family and you knew he
never gave anybody a lecture about what
to do
he he just lit he was a good example
and um
and he had the money and he made the
money
we were middle middle class family so we
were like
Little Red Brick House White brick
actually white Brick House about 1400
square feet seven people lived in it
and my dad I could tell my dad was
trying to get somewhere he was trying to
move us up
he was trying and he wasn't trying to
brag
he was trying to take care of
and so I was watching that right and I
watched where this guy he he's the one
that made the decision where we went how
long we stayed and I started associating
that the money maker makes the rules
this is what Elena was talking about you
know there's around the money I make the
rules around the money around other
things Elena makes the rules so you got
to know what you're good at and what
your job is and what your role is my dad
and my mom knew their roles
[Music]
problem with that is when my dad died
suddenly at 52 years old my mom was left
to do something she didn't she didn't
have she was not skilled up to do
and I was 10 and I wasn't I didn't know
how to help my mom
my dad left a little bit of insurance
money from the from the life insurance
or the death Insurance better better
it's really Called Death Insurance just
can't sell it if they call it that and
my mom didn't know how long that money
would last so immediately after my dad
died when my mom should have been in
grief she she would went immediately
into massive fear and I could see it I
could sense it as a 10 year old my mom
was in fear every day
clipping coupons saving money you know
turn the lights off
eat all your food it was constant
messages
go across town to get gas like
everything you can't buy strawberries
today
you know they'll be there'll be 20 cents
cheaper tomorrow everything was about
fear
and so I I couldn't do anything about it
or didn't think I could do anything
about it
and I just kept telling myself one day
one day I'm gonna be in a position to
change this
and I think that really drives me today
to like
take care of
people not be in that situation again
you know this concept of work
that the wealthy don't work hard I hear
this constantly you know rich people
don't work hard you know rich people
rich people work smart
that that you got to be kidding right
rich people take all the vacations it's
not true rich people don't take all the
vacation the vacation industry the
vacation industry literally is built off
the middle class not the wealthy
now you might not like this concept but
I'm going to tell you the truth this is
a report that just recently came out
okay one of the most controversial
issues surrounding inequality is work
effort this is a concept of why do the
rich get richer and those people that
don't have or don't have enough keep
sliding down the scale and that's what I
do in these Grant rants is I'm talking
to the middle class about look do you
see it disappearing it's going away
okay the middle class is getting erased
I came from the middle class and I see
what's happening to it what we used 20
or 30 years ago or 40 years ago to build
a middle class is not working for us
today for instance work hard okay you
see there's this concept that no you
don't need to work hard you just need to
work smart if you work smart you get the
right connections you'll get rich that's
not true this is what it says in this in
this article I found this in the wealth
report do the wealthy work harder than
the rest you might want to Google it a
new study offers evidence that higher
education and therefore higher earning
okay Americans do indeed spend more time
working and less time on Leisure than
poorer income groups okay it's been
validated in this study it says in fact
while incoming inequality inequality may
be growing which it is Leisure
inequality time spent on enjoyment okay
time spent on enjoyment is a growing in
a mirror image what is that saying
people that are actually making less
money and less wealth are actually
spending more time in Leisure why
because of myths you were taught a myth
you were taught this concept of enjoy my
life you know I gotta enjoy my life I
need to enjoy the day the wealthy don't
think like that I'm telling you the most
successful people don't think about
enjoying life I gotta enjoy they think
about luxury man they think about the
Big Bang they think about the big big
win not the little two-day vacation
what they do is they'll suffer their
whole life so they go go on vacation
later when there's wealth for two and
three months at a time you get it work
hard okay work hard it is a myth that
you're not going to work hard I'm
working harder today than I ever have in
my life
most people only work hard enough
that they're always working you get it
most people only work so hard that they
feel like they're always slaves remember
this anytime you feel like a slave
you've let somebody else be your master
you know what I'm talking about junk
people buy junk people go on vacations
people waste time and they don't have
any money don't let that be you who in
the room likes sales you're like I just
love
you love it okay stay away from this man
keep your kids away from it stay away
from him okay it's a whack job right
here okay anybody that likes sales he
only likes it because he's good at it
because there was a time when he didn't
like it nobody naturally likes
approaching a person
presenting a product
asking them to buy it like everybody
gets uncomfortable right
so so one thing one trick I thought that
that was the whole trick in business
like I got to go out and sell something
that's not the trick you need to build a
business and everybody in here's the
business she is a business her job is to
get attention for her brand discover her
brand clarify her brand yeah that's my
brand don't be stealing on my brand but
she could she could she could ride she
could ride she's collaborating with me
when she does that she collaborating
with a brand we we invited you here so
we could collaborate with you
how many of you went to our conference
here in Miami okay oh a few of you okay
it's 35 000 people there
35 000. I have more people in Marlin
stadium
than the Marlins can put in their
Stadium
the Marlins and the Dolphins
that just shows you how important
success is
Right some of you were going to go to
the game this Sunday you're like I ain't
going hey I wouldn't go here much less
New York right so because nobody wants
to be around losers like bottom line so
you got to get yourselves it's easy to
talk about the Dolphins right okay but
but you got to get yourself in a
position where you win it folks
you know I remember there was a time in
my life where I I didn't want to be
around me
I knew I had this much potential and I
was delivering like right here I I
didn't like me I hated me
same thing when I started having a
business my business had three or four
employees
I didn't like that about me because I
knew I should have more employees earn
some power earned the right to have some
power some responsibility keep the power
okay and say and multiply it you want
you want to multiply it you don't want
to hoard it it's not about keeping it to
keep it for yourself it's about how do I
now multiply this is what your mom and
dad said this is what my mom and dad
didn't know they knew how to keep it
they did not know how to multiply stuff
okay that's why with most of your if I'm
right about you in this audience just
from looking at you judging you a little
bit is you were probably brought up the
way I was eat all your food
I remember taught that three times a day
eat it all eat it all eat it all if you
didn't eat it all put it in the
refrigerator you're like look I didn't
want it hot I'm not going to want it
tomorrow
I don't want this this done I don't know
shave it save it somebody somewhere
starving somebody somewhere and I'm like
dude like like you you guys go back to
your refrigerator tonight see if you're
not affected by this open your
refrigerator and look in and see how
much
that you
see how much stuff
from Jared see how much stuff that
you're saving that you don't want
that you don't want to eat the only
reason you're saving stuff you don't
want is because you're worried about
earning more
period Then I want you to walk to your
closet just a little exercise go to your
closet open your closet I want you to
look at shoes pants slacks jackets that
you haven't worn in years
probably don't even fit you but you
refuse to throw them away
to save it
I gotta save it I got to save it because
you're worried about earning money
enough money to pay for more stuff
because you know in your heart of hearts
you know that mechanism for you is
broken
you have to fix this you have a
responsibility to fix it so you can do
nothing tonight
okay it will not get better you can go
do it on your own
[Music]
most of you look like you've had enough
time how old are you sir
but he's had enough time at 41. dude if
you ain't fixing to 41 uh whatever data
you have
got you in that chair and that that's
that's what I know about myself I have
to change for me to change I have to
change and for the for the most part
that doesn't mean I need to do more it
means I need new information so when we
wrote the 10x rule
I mean all books that I write all the
books that I write I write for me I'm
not writing for you okay somebody else
gets something out of it good I write
the book sit down it's a way for me to
like re like hey what am I what what do
I have to do to go to the next place I'm
not trying to sell a book to make money
there's no money in selling a book you
get 15 cents
sell a book stupid right so Elena's
finishing a book right now now she
realizes how dumb it is
because it's hard
so when we wrote the 10x rule our
advertising budget was almost nothing
almost zero we'll spend 12 plus million
dollars this year in advertising when I
wrote the 10x rule the company was doing
about 600 Grand a year this year we'll
do 150 million bucks
so would you spend 12 million dollars
thank you would you spend 12 million
dollars to make 150 million dollars a
year
okay the first the first three or four
million dollars is not going to get you
the explosion and it's probably not
going to happen in Year One
okay you start spending that kind of
money you do need employees
you need people answering the telephone
you need people on websites you need
people building landing pages you need
graphics
okay anybody thinking different right
now anybody right now thinking hey dude
I gotta bring it I got I gotta swell up
here some of you spend more time in the
gym than
any time some of you spend too much time
at the movie
what are you doing
I want to spend time on my financial
statement what part of that financial
statement do I want to spend time on
Top Line
okay how many treasury people here
Finance people treasury accountants CFOs
raise your hand if you are
congratulations for being here okay let
me see your hand again if you're CFO
treasury Finance okay good how many of
you do not have a finance person with
you here today
dude you need to get those people here
they're holding your company back their
brakes
they sit on breaks we spend that much
money is Susan here today Sherry
okay good Susan's the finance I'm glad
she's not here she'll hear this from my
people okay so Susan is a financial
person and she works in my real estate
division and and once a week we have a
meeting
and yesterday she was in my office and
she's like if we do listen listen this
we're not going to do this and I said
dude dude look look I didn't ask you for
that
you're the finance person
you're not the entrepreneur here
you let me figure out how to pick it and
how to make it work you just report the
numbers tell me if there's any Outlets
keep everything clean keep it ethical
you ain't the business person here
Finance is not business
right so who gave you your your business
advice where are you getting it from I
don't get it from somebody that's
conservative
you understand I'm not going to give it
for somebody that's in conservation mode
conservation is a tone level it is a
tone it was like I want to protect
things
you have kids you don't have kids and
then you have kids does it change you
you immediately go into conservation
okay a woman a woman she's a freak she's
a total freak everybody knows she's a
freak she has a kid
she pulls it back in she's like oh can't
be a freak anymore man Elaine I'm
talking about my wife
total freak as a kid
turns into a Republican
starts dressing nice
I know no no she starts conserving she's
trying to protect you understand
somebody doesn't have any money you give
them a couple million bucks they're
going to go into conservation mode or
they're going to go broke you have to go
into conservation mode first
but if you stay in conservation mode if
you're taking notes you want to write
this down if you stay in conservation
mode
you will lose it all this is the secret
of the successful people this is what
I've committed my life to do it I told
my mom when I was 16 years old one day
I'm going to be successful and one day
I'm going to help a lot of people I
always say this pay the price today so
you can pay any price in the future my
buddies were traveling seeing the world
and I didn't have any of those
experiences I've had people tell me hey
you Market too much you Market too
aggressively my office tells me we hit
the list too much look I've been
ridiculed by my peers my customers and
by competition I've been judged for
working too much wanting too much being
too colorful being inappropriate
insensitive and too out there I'm trying
to figure it out I've been threatened
I've been sued I've been betrayed by
friends I've been ripped off and I've
been copied I've been married 15 years
to Elena not one time has she ever said
you work too much not one time she has
never said to me what are you doing
getting home so late she knows what I'm
doing I'm trying to get to 10x levels
it's probably going to be 30 years for
you to doubt and certainty insecurities
rejection if anybody thinks you're going
to be successful without paying that
price you're wrong I threw myself I
threw my that addiction thing I had into
my work
uh I started picking different people in
my life I got rid of everybody that was
there one of the hardest things that
people can do if you want to elevate you
gotta eliminate
and I just made a list of everybody I
needed out of my life and they were
liabilities I still do this today I
assess who's a liability and who's an
asset in my life does not matter how
much I care for you it does not matter
what the lat your last name is it don't
matter if I was born with you you're my
sister my mother my brother my daddy my
uncle my aunt or my best friend if you
are a liability to yourself and me
I'm cutting you
like I don't do barbecues with people
that that are liabilities you can't pay
your own bills I don't spend time with
you you're sick all the time I don't
spend time with you you cheating on your
husband I don't spend time with you I
don't spend time with anybody that are
treasonous or a liability
and it doesn't matter but we could have
we could have been cool for five years
and all of a sudden something happens to
you Clint was good for five years and
then something happened and Clint starts
doing stupid stuff I'm like bro time out
me and you gonna take a time out
I treat my friends and my family like
the NBA or the the MLB or the you know
NFL you don't you're not performing
you're cut from the team
and it's it's it's one of the most
important policies of my life most
people don't know how to create money
okay the most important thing about
money and getting what you want is not
to have the money it's to create the
things you want live where you want have
the expansion you want the views you
want go where you want number one you
have to know how to make it most people
don't know how to make money number two
fewer people know how to keep it that's
discipline you got to have discipline
and you're not going to have discipline
if you don't have goals why would I keep
money
if my goals are either perverted
short-sighted or maybe too small okay so
you got to have monster goals and and
that's going to create the discipline
necessary to keep what you went out and
earned and number three number three
then you got to figure out how to
multiply it okay now you don't need to
figure out how to multiply it when I was
25 years old and I'm broke I didn't need
to work on multiplying it I didn't even
need to work on keeping it because I
didn't have any
in the beginning in the very beginning
from the age of 25 to 35 all I did was
work on particularly in the first three
or four years all I worked on all I
worked on was how do I learn how to sell
man I think it's bright how do I learn
how to sell how do I learn how to Market
how do I learn how to promote how do I
learn how to handle people's objections
I'm talking about basic basic stuff I am
not here to satisfy you I am not here so
you like oh oh Grant I like him I don't
care if you like me or not man I want to
move a handful of people in the room to
go from 400 Grand a year to start
thinking about how do I make 4 million
big boy right over here popping out what
did you make last year
would you gross last year
2.7 how does any live
you need to make it impossible dude I
cannot I can't my my plane eats 2.7
million dollars a year the this dude
needs to think different
he's running out of time man you guys
all in the room man you're running out
of time you're in a space that is so
frothy with opportunity it's
unbelievable you're making sense of less
than you can get this is my mama my
mama's saying I love you boy just the
way you are Mama I made 10 million
dollars on one deal that's great but son
I love you just the way you are I'm like
I don't love me just the way I am
because I'm doing deals where I know I
could make a hundred
okay how many of you in a room are
operating below your potential let me
see your hand if you know you're
operating below your potential man
please tell me you're up early how how
many of you let me see your hand again
if you're operating below your potential
okay your finances should indicate that
your finances are a way to tell the
truth about who you are your space like
if you're an Uber driver and you're
making 2.7 million a year
pat on the back
you're in this space making 2.7 million
here come on man your company's doing
what 2 billion
two billion dollars and you guys aren't
getting it all would you say that you're
not getting it up
a lot of room he's telling me he's in
the first Innings of his game so so I'm
like hey what what do I need to do let's
say 400 is the number then I'm gonna
take this and I'm just going to 10x that
and I'm gonna build a business plan for
four million dollars
and I'm gonna quit thinking I'm going to
quit thinking that I that I got to do a
four minute mile
I'm going to quit thinking about the
physical Universe what can I do to
produce four million dollars
is it here is it outside of here is it
here and outside of here how many
customers would I need this is what this
is what my goal for you today is to
leave here and say dude I ain't
satisfied
okay I want to raise the numbers on this
room so the next time there's 75 people
here and everybody adds a zero to your
income oh by the way if you love
yourself at 400 Grand mama
if you love your son just the way he is
at 400 would you love me a little more
if I add a zero no she couldn't love me
anymore it wasn't up to her to love me
it was up to me to love what I'm doing
every day right you guys are showing up
you're working your ass off every day
right or wrong
how many of you making calls every day
you're like I do not want to make this
call and you make it anyway good then
get paid for it
get paid some real money for it man okay
get paid some real money just had a zero
how many calls would I have to make is
this even possible he's doing part of it
he told me I'm not he's not tapped into
all of it
he's hitting 70 percent of that number
if everybody walked out of here and said
hey I'm gonna build a four million
dollar plan I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you a little a little game I play I
got 14 little companies I run 14 little
companies while I'm doing deals while
I'm speaking to you today right I'm
still running them in my head right now
I got them all open I got browsers open
all over the place
counselor said you got add I said I
ain't got add I don't know how to add I
multiply
I'm done adding I'm done adding a
customer I want to multiply customers I
want to I don't want to add orders I
want to multiply my orders okay I
consider myself a decent salesperson
but it doesn't matter if you're a great
salesperson if you don't add business to
the sale if you don't become a business
person you can't build out zeros
because you're going to hit you're going
to hit a place where they can't pay you
anymore right or wrong
you got to start thinking about being a
business inside the business
how do I add zeros how do I grow the top
line of my business okay so today I'm
thinking I'm thinking man I'm going to
build a mo I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I just go into
it backwards I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I'm gonna take
the 14 little things that I have
probably get down to three or four how
do I build 10 billion
I know the money's on the planet
say yay if you agree there's 10 billion
dollars on planet Earth dude you could
you could suck 10 billion dollars off
planet Earth today and you wouldn't they
wouldn't even give you like you wouldn't
even make the paper
I just got to think different and I
can't compare it to my upbringing what
are you gonna do when are you going to
start doing it
this isn't about a convention a
conference it's not about enthusiasm do
you need to smile yeah you need to smile
you need to smile like you're crazy
you need a smile when you're not winning
okay but you need to do something folks
and you need to do it 10 times and then
a hundred times and then a thousand
times and if you do it enough times
you're gonna win
you're gonna get to sit wherever you
want in life on whatever plane seat
whatever Hotel you want to be at stay as
long as you want come and go as you want
if you don't want to go you're like dude
just cancel the plants
but but we're inside of 24 hours they're
gonna keep our money keep it
I can get some more
it wasn't even mine
okay the money I got in my pocket right
now nope see Elena's got it all
the money Elena has in her purse
with somebody else's money
see but we're taught that there's a
shortage in their scarcity and you don't
have any all you have to do is be
willing to call somebody
talk to somebody
make contact
if it's not getting you the result tweak
the contact and increase the calls
and by the way if you don't want to do
two things don't tweak and just increase
the calls
if I call enough people I can say
anything I want to say
okay if you're taking notes write this
down no one thing will ever blow a
prospect
no one thing will ever blow a prospect
there's nothing you can say that will
mess a deal up not one thing people
should like just start journaling how
many times they're making commitments in
their life and what needs to be juggled
by the way something always has to be
given up
you know there's so much that has to be
surrendered to get something else like
Game Changer your t-shirt for me to wear
that shirt I'd have to either take this
one off or put yours on top of it but
something would have to change
and Peter there's so many people out
there there are talking about it man
here we are at the beginning of the year
I want to lose weight I want to add
muscle I want a better relationship I
want the right girl do you you if you
want the right girl you can't keep going
to the same strip joint
okay if you want to quit drinking
alcohol you got to quit going to the bar
if you don't want to smoke any more
wheat and you think it's slowing you
down then you you got to quit going to
the medicinal Place picking it up lying
to people that you got something wrong
with you when there's nothing wrong with
you right if you don't want to if you
want to act like you're a freaking a
superhero quit parking in the handicap
Zone
I used to do that I'm like I'm gonna get
me one of those stickers so I can park
in the handicap Zone and somebody said
bro you you you're going to tell people
that you're handicapped
like you're gonna advertise that you're
a handicapped even if you are
you wouldn't want that freaking piece of
paper
right and the guy looked at me says why
don't you just park in the fire zone bro
if you're in that much of a hurry Park
out there and let the car get towed away
I said that's a good dog put yourself in
a position where they can tow your car
away and you can get it back
you see what I'm saying so everybody's
got to give something up when I studied
and this is really really important for
everybody you guys start studying
successful people
you know if you want to be a Salesman
the rest of your life and live off
commissions the rest of your life great
study the best sales people out there
but I'm gonna tell you something if you
want to make your life easier
start figuring out how to scale your
sales
and the way to scale your sales is
through marketing I'd rather have 10
people buy from me than one people than
have to sell one person
yeah you know I don't want the hard sale
anymore I want the easy sales and this
isn't about like yeah I don't mind
working hard I got I know how to work
hard but I don't want to work hard every
day
I'd like to work more
at collecting more fruit that wants to
fall off the tree the easy sales and
marketing is the only way to make sales
easy word tracks do not make the sale
easier I mean they'll make it better
you know it'll handle an objection uh
follow-up you know tremendous follow-up
will make we'll we'll almost guarantee
you a sale but in between the follow-up
if you want to speed up your sales cycle
for instance if you're in a sales cycle
that typically is very very long the
only way to make that sales cycle
shorter is through marketing and trust
and marketing is the only thing that
builds trust it's not what you say how
you say or how you dress it is the
frequency at which you show up in
people's ideas or thoughts it's called
omnipresence and we'll teach you how to
do that in January
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Robert Kiyosaki
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there how do you build
up from there if I had to do it again I
go work for McDonald's the reason I go
work for McDonald's you know whether
it's seven bucks an hour or 15. I don't
really care they have the best Business
Systems in the world so right inside
little McDonald's